when you hit Legend status the way you
have there's certain myths that pop up
that seem to follow artists around so I
wanted to do a little segment we call
Dolly do or Dolly don't and bust some of
these myths ready okay is it true that
you sleep with full hair full makeup
most nights when you're on the road
well I don't I always wear my makeup and
I always if I don't have my own hair
fixed I have a wig on a lampshade or
something because you never know when
you're gonna have to exit a building and
it's like when I live in it when I live
in LA I have a place out there and
there's always earthquakes and other
things and you know you're always thrown
out in the streets and TV cameras at all
you gotta be ready yeah I think it
doesn't matter when you clean your face
as long as you clean it in a 24-hour
period so I usually sleep in my makeup
and then I get up and clean my face put
it on again yeah so I try to stay
everybody
just in case I love this about you and
my husband likes it too he does yeah he
likes it better than going to bed with a
shower cap and clear seal on my face at
least I look good you've been married
for 56 years this is what works and I
approve yeah
okay is it true that you love tattoos
and that you're covered in them under
your clothes I have a few tattoos
they're not uh for the sake of tattoos
although I enjoy seeing them because
they're pastels but I have a Tennessee
Scar and my scarf you know I'm so fair
and if I uh if I have something that I
just feel like I'd rather not look at
that scar then I'll I'll dress it up a
little bit so yeah it's true I have
sometimes okay I love that is it true
that you have an entire room dedicated
to your wigs and hair pieces uh well I
have a closet that has shelves right
here yeah and my foreclosed hair and
makeup is really just a room for that
type of stuff but I'm always on I'm
always changing clothes every day you
know so yeah I have I have areas in any
house that I'm in and I carry like if I
carry wig trunks on the road I have
trunks made that you don't care about
three to three to five rigs that you
have if you're doing shows it's just so
handy yeah and you know just trying to
do my own hair that much that high that
I used to do it years ago before the
Rings and it's just not all that healthy
plus I'm too busy to sit and do that you
are busy yeah so this works I'm too
fidgety too yeah
I appreciate that it's one of the
wildest rumors that you've heard about
yourself oh heavens I've heard
everything so I don't know I don't think
there's anything I ever know well I
think there was one time a in inquire
magazine that my boobs were so heavy
that it had they had broken my back down
and that I couldn't get up and I was
going to be crippled for the rest of my
life or something like that and I
thought well they are big and they are
heavy but I can still get around with it
I'm doing all right my back's okay my
back's all right if I had a back problem
I don't think it's because